Atentos, os hago una pregunta, ¿Cuál diríais
que es el mayor sueño de un narcotraficante?
El mayor de todos..
Vamos a ver, me explico, todos tenemos sueños,
tu, yo, lo políticos… y desde luego, los
narcos no son una excepción
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, aunque resulte
difícil de creer, en el corazón de la despiadada
y cruel industria del Narcotráfico hay seres
humanos con nombres, apellidos - y en este
caso también apodos - que como todos los
demás mortales también tienen sus propios
sueños.
Ahora bien… ¿Cuál es el mayor de todos?
Supongo que respuestas posibles hay muchas,
¿No os parece?
Pues… no, no os equivoqueis.
Para desgracia de todos los demás… la historia
nos dice que si los narcos pudieran pedir
un deseo, tan sólo un deseo… este no sería
otro que convertir a sus países en auténticos
narcoestados.
Es decir, me explico: en estados dirigidos
por una especie de corporación delictiva
formada por políticos, funcionarios públicos,
jueces, policías y militares que de una forma
u otra están asociados con el narco.
De esta forma, los narcotraficantes pueden
actuar prácticamente con total impunidad,
importante, exportando y distribuyendo narcóticos
sin ninguna restricción.
Precisamente, hace muy poquito tiempo hablamos
aquí, en VisualPolitik, de cómo el régimen
bolivariano de Nicolás Maduro, Diosdado Cabello
y el Cartel de los Soles estaba convirtiendo
a Venezuela en todo un narcoestado.
Sin embargo, amigos, por desgracia, en Latinoamérica,
la narcopolítica va mucho más allá de Venezuela.
En este vídeo vamos a conocer un poco mejor,
como un personaje fue capaz de impulsar la
alianza entre la industria de los narcóticos
y los políticos. Atentos.
(EL NARCOPOPULISMO)
Todos lo sabemos: la industria de los narcóticos
es uno de los negocios ilegales más importantes.
Cada año mueve varios de cientos de miles
de millones de dólares.
Ahora bien, os hago una segunda pregunta, ¿pensáis
acaso que un cartel puede sobrevivir sin apoyo
político? ¿Sin controlar de alguna forma
las instituciones?
Amigos, para contestar a esta pregunta vayamos
a los orígenes y echemos un vistazo a cómo
lograron poder los narcos más importantes
de todos los tiempos…
Porque si bien es cierto que en sus inicios
el narcotráfico surge como poco más que
un grupo de bandidos al margen de la ley,
hay un momento donde todo eso cambia…
Un momento… y un protagonista:
Pablo Escobar Gaviria, considerado por la
Revista Forbes como una de las mayores fortunas
de su época en todo el planeta.
Según esta revista, en 1987, Pablo Escobar
Gaviria, era propietario de una de una fortuna
que superaba los 2.000 millones de dólares
de aquella época…
Y es que, Pablo Escobar cambió radicalmente
la industria de los narcóticos en todo el
mundo.
(Por un lado, creó todo un entramado, un
holding criminal que incluía “negocios”
como la extorsión, el secuestro, el sicariato
y, por supuesto, la actividad estrella, el
tráfico de narcóticos.
Todas estas actividades estaban, además,
perfectamente integradas en una estructura,
el Cartel de Medellín, que tenía organigrama
claro, una jerarquía definida e, incluso,
una distribución por zonas…con sus propios
responsables al mando. Algo así cómo si
de franquicias o sucursales se tratará.
Por otro lado, amigos, en lo que respecta
al que fue su negocio estrella…los narcóticos…
este Cartel, el Cártel de Medellín, logró
una integración vertical casi completa.
Es decir, el Cartel se hacían cargo de la
cosecha, la producción, la distribución
y la comercialización de la inmensa mayor
parte de su mercancía. Lo hacían todo, copaban
todas las etapas del negocio. )
De esta forma es como el Cartel de Medellín
logró facturar más de 7.000 millones de
dólares de la época cada año.
Claro que… un momento… nada de esto hubiera
sido posible sin la complicidad de los poderes
públicos.
("Aparentemente Escobar alcanzó la cima del
cartel de la cocaína al reinvertir astutamente
sus ganancias iniciales y convertirse en un
maestro de las relaciones públicas en Colombia
[…] Con su creciente riqueza, Escobar compró
un periódico en Medellín, ganó influencia
en la política colombiana y se postuló con
éxito a un cargo público, convirtiéndose
en una alternativa para el congreso nacional.”
David Henry, Revista Forbes 1987.)
Veréis, durante muchos años Pablo Escobar
gozó de impunidad… con su dinero y sus
amenazas - la conocida frase de plata o plomo
- logró infiltrarse en el Estado colombiano.
Sobornó a militares, políticos, gobernadores,
policías…de tal forma que muchas de las
instituciones colombianas estuvieron durante
mucho a su tiempo a su orden y mando.
Y eso no es todo. Pablo Escobar también financió
campañas electorales y para ganarse el apoyo
popular - ¿Qué hace un político cuando
quiere ganar popularidad por la vía rápida
- impulsó proyectos como la construcción
de viviendas para los más pobres, el reparto
de víveres y el desarrollo de campos de fútbol.
Suena bien, ¿Verdad? A primera vista… todo
un Robin Hood colombiano.
Lástima que la realidad fuera tan diferente.
Mientras llevaba a cabo este tipo de campañas,
este criminal no tuvo reparos en inundar las
calles con violencia y sangre.
Bienvenidos al Narcopopulismo.
El caso, es que como todo sabéis… Pablo
Escobar…llegó en 1982 a ostentar un escaño
en el Parlamento Colombiano.
Hasta ese momento, gracias a sus “influencias
políticas” y a sus estrategias de relaciones
públicas, este personaje pudo construir su
imperio y su inmensa fortuna con la más absoluta
impunidad.
("Un miembro de la Agencia Antidrogas de Estados
Unidos dijo una vez que la importación de
animales exóticos para su zoológico parecía
haberle generado a Escobar más problemas
frente al gobierno que su negocio de narcóticos”.
David Henry)
Ahora bien… un momento.
No pensáis que las “relaciones políticas”
de Pablo Escobar se limitaban a Colombia,
para nada.
Fijaos… tras su elección como diputado…
la situación se hizo insostenible.
Algunos medios de comunicación empezaron
a contar la verdad que se escondía tras su
fortuna; las presiones de la DEA se multiplicaron,
buena parte de la sociedad colombiana comprendió
el enorme peligro que Pablo Escobar suponía
y otros carteles empezaron a sentir pavor
de que el poder de Medellín creciera a un
más.
Y ahí fue cuando el gobierno comenzó la
persecución contra este capo… que ni corto
ni perezoso le declaró la guerra al mismísimo
estado colombiano.
Y por si acaso, lo primero que hizo fue largarse
no sea que le fueran a cazar.
(EL SALTO)
Pablo Escobar puso tierra de por medio, se
largó de Colombia.
La pregunta es, ¿Dónde podría encontrar
refugio? ¿Serían los dólares del narcotráfico
suficientes para estrechar alianzas?
Pues… parece que sí.
En primer lugar Panamá… En aquel momento
el dictador militar, Manuel Antonio Noriega
le ofreció asilo, protección y también
una ruta para poder transportar su mercancía.
Imaginaos si esta industria era poderosa que
hasta los dictadores estaban dispuestos a
vender sus servicios.
(El caso es que cómo veis, Noriega también
convirtió a Panamá en un narcoestado hasta
que en 1989, una invasión relámpago de Estados
Unidos le depuso del poder… Detenido y trasladado
a los Estados Unidos, el propio Noriega fue
condenado 30 años de cárcel por sus vínculos
con el tráfico de narcóticos… y con el
propio Cartel de Medellín.)
Pero… no, aquí no terminan las alianzas
exteriores de Pablo Escobar Gaviria.
Lo cierto es que en Panamá no se sentía
muy seguro…
Vamos a ver, Sí, Noriega por así decirlo
era un colega… pero la CIA tenía mucha
presencia en el país… así que el día
menos esperado Noriega podría tener la tentación
de venderle.
Porque, claro, una cosa era hacer negocios
con el dictador panameño y otra muy distinta
confiarle su protección.
Tocaba buscar nuevo destino.
De esta forma, A través de la guerrilla colombiana
de izquierdas Movimiento 19 de abril, más
conocido como M-19 o simplemente como el eme,
Pablo Escobar se puso en contacto con el gobierno
de Nicaragua.
(La Junta de Gobierno Sandinista liderada
por el actual presidente del país Daniel
Ortega estaban dispuestos a recibirle con
los brazos abiertos a cambio de una comisión…
ya sabéis, por los servicios prestados.
El acuerdo contemplaba que Pablo podría utilizar
algunas regiones de Nicaragua como plataforma
de distribución para los narcóticos además
de instalarse en el país junto a su familia.
¿Problema? Ortega y compañía eran muy codiciosos…
así que unos meses después Pablo decidió
regresar a Colombia. Claro que las relaciones
de negocio se mantuvieron.
Junto a Nicaragua, la guerrilla M-19 también
facilitó el contacto del Cartel de Medellín
con el gobierno de Cuba…)
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis, Cuba también
fue también una plataforma de operaciones
para los negocios de Pablo Escobar. De hecho,
se sabe, que Pablo Escobar mantenía buenas
relaciones con los hermanos Castro.
[Aunque, la verdad, parece que no fue el único,
todo apunta a que después de Escobar, otros
narcos continuaron utilizando Cuba, acuerdo
con los Castro mediante, para introducir todo
tipo de narcóticos en los Estados Unidos.]
Colombia, Panamá, Nicaragua, Cuba… ya lo
veis, el propio poder político fue uno de
los principales impulsores de la enorme presencia
que el narco tiene en América Latina.
La falta de transparencia, la corrupción,
la falta de contrapesos y las instituciones
débiles fueron un caldo de cultivo perfecto…
para lo que con el paso de los años se ha
convertido en una de las grandes pesadillas
de la región.
Y sí, puede que alguno esté pensando…
bueno, Enrique, tanto, tanto… pero al final
Pablo Escobar cayó. Es verdad, pero lo cierto
es que cuando un capó cae no quiere decir
que ocurra lo mismo con la industria… ni
con sus relaciones con el poder político.
Echemos un vistazo a México.
(EL RELEVO)
El principal cartel mexicano con el que Pablo
Escobar tuvo relaciones fue el Cartel de Guadalajara,
liderado por Ernesto Fonseca - que no tiene
nada que ver con nuestro Fonseca - por Rafael
Caro Quintero y Miguel Ángel Felix Gallardo.
Este cartel gozo de plena impunidad durante
2 décadas… todo gracias a sus relaciones
con el poder.
Felix Gallardo era el encargado de las “relaciones
públicas”… y gracias a su capacidad para
moverse en las altas esferas políticas este cártel tuvo
toda la estabilidad y tranquilidad para crecer
y desarrollarse.
¡Qué importante es tener un buen relaciones públicas!
(Sin embargo… estamos hablando de una industria
criminal… y en las organizaciones criminales…
la estabilidad es muy difícil. En este caso,
el asalto al agente de la DEA,
Enrique Camarena, que terminó
con su vida, supuso que Washington exigiera
la desarticulación de este cartel… y uno
a uno sus líderes fueron cayendo.
Pero… no se terminó con el negocio. Desde
la cárcel, en 1989, Felix Gallardo trato
de reorganizar los territorios… pero ante
la falta de acuerdo el Cártel se dividió
en dos:
El Cártel de Tijuana liderato por los hermanos
Arellano y el Cartel de Sinaloa liderado por
Héctor Luis Palma Salazar “El güero Palma”
y Joaquín Guzmán Loera, alias “el Chapo”,
que en el año 2009 debutó en la lista Forbes
con una fortuna estimada de más de 1.000
millones de dólares.)
El caso es que bajo el mando del Chapo, el
Cartel de Sinaloa se convirtió en el cártel
más importante e influyente de México y
en una de las organizaciones criminales más
importantes del mundo.
La pregunta que seguro alguno de vosotros
se está haciendo es… ¿Cómo lo logró?
¿Cómo un Cártel puede conseguir crecer
mucho más que sus adversarios?
Pues sobre todo… por las influencias políticas.
Por ejemplo, ¿Cómo evitas que la policía
federal te atrape y desmantele tu negocio?
Pues… por ejemplo, enterándote de cuando
se van a producir esas redadas.
Todo pasa por tener buenas relaciones… y
eso es precisamente lo que el Chapo se aseguro
de tener. La información y los “amigos”
son poder.
Y, tal y como ya hemos visto en otros casos,
la captura del Chapo no cambió esencialmente
el panorama.
Hoy el Cartel de Sinaloa es controlado por
Ismael “el Mayo” Zambada, que según se
sabe a lo largo del tiempo ha logrado comprar
incluso a funcionarios de la Fiscalía especializada,
de la Procuraduría General de la República
y hasta del Centro de Inteligencia Antinarcóticos,
un cuerpo de élite del ejército creado para
luchar contra los narcos.
("Obviamente que esos negocios no los hacen
solos, sino que en no pocos casos cuentan
con la aprobación o participación de autoridades",
F.J.R investigador de la Universidad de Guadalajara)
Todo siempre con la complicidad de altos cargos
del gobierno.
(Así y sólo así se explica el poder, la
fuerza y la resiliencia de estos grupos criminales.
Con el apoyo del poder político… con el
cual en muchos casos crean una simbiosis difícil
de distinguir.
Es lo que está ocurriendo en Venezuela con
el Cartel de los Soles del que ya os hemos
hablado aquí en VisualPolitik. Y ojo, porque
se calcula que entre los carteles mexicanos
y venezolanos controlan el 70% de los narcóticos
que entran en los Estados Unidos.)
Es lo mismo que ocurre en países como Guatemala
donde algunas informaciones apuntan, ojo,
que hasta un 80% de los polvos blancos podrían
ser intermediados por miembros del ejército;
o lo que ocurre en Honduras, donde incluso
el hijo del expresidente Porfirio Lobo ha
sido condenado en los Estados Unidos por actividades
de narcotráfico mientras su padre era el
mismísimo Presidente de la República.
En fin, amigos, este es el resultado de las
instituciones débiles, de la falta de transparencia
y de la falta de contrapesos. En VisualPolitik
hablaremos mucho de esta cuestión que tan
cara está resultando para muchos países
latinoamericanos.
Con este vídeo os hemos querido mostrar unas
pinceladas de cómo algunos de los grandes
narcos consiguieron su “Éxito” en gran
medida gracias a su influencia sobre las instituciones.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.